the left wants to overthrow nature
itself there's a line that kennedy used
to quote john f kennedy
he would say this is supposed to be a
great inspiration he'd say some people
see things that are and say
why i dream things that never were and
say
why not and he acknowledged he got this
line from george bernard shaw what he
didn't know
is that the line from shaw comes from
this play cycle back to methuselah
and the line actually comes from the
mouth of the serpent tempting eve in the
garden of eden
the line that shaw is giving here that
kennedy is quoting
and a lot of democrats have quoted since
then is the
language of the devil we need total
delusion we need to embrace delusion
well that is what the left is doing
in human nature not just among
consenting adults but even
among children in a really disturbing
case out of
texas
he's a ten-year-old boy in texas he just
spoke before the texas state senate
he spoke to them regarding bill 1646
this is a bill
that acknowledges that it is child abuse
to chemically castrate children
and give them transsex hormones and
mutilate their bodies to make little
boys look more like little girls
so this little boy testifies
before the committee i
hesitated even to play this clip but
it's it's really out there it's
obviously very very public already i'm
gonna i'm gonna blur
the kid's face and i'm not gonna refer
to the kid's name because
his mother is obviously abusing him
uh listen to his testimony
to see how far the country's gotten
hello my name is um
i love ballet math science and geology
i spend my free time with my cats
chickens face timing my friends
and dreaming of when i will finally meet
dolly parton
i do not like spending my free time
asking adults to make good choices
i've been having to explain myself since
i was
three or four years old
texas legislators have been attacking me
since pre-k
i am in fourth grade now
when it comes to bills that target trans
youth i immediately
feel angry it's been very scary and
overwhelming
it just it makes me sad that some
politicians use trans kids like me
to get votes from people who hate me
just because i exist
god made me god loves me for who i am
and god does not make mistakes my mom
has been giving everything she has to
stand up for me
wow there and there it is you can listen
to the
you can listen to the rest of this if
you want to i suspect you don't
but you hear that line my mom has been
so wonderful and there
there it is if you didn't already know
from the first part of this that this
poor little boy is being
horrifically abused by his mother you
get it there i don't believe that the
boy
came up with these lines on his own of
course of course he didn't
and uh the this rehearsed sort of
caricature
of of what a woman is that he is
performing
i don't think this was an invention of
his own i think this was put into his
head obviously
the idea that he's been trying to
convince adults of
of reality since he was three years old
is obviously not true
three-year-olds don't convince anybody
of anything because three-year-olds
don't know anything because they're
they're very little is that does that
still count as a toddler
i don't know i'm not really familiar
with all the various designations
you're a very very little kid when
you're three years old and this
kid's pervert mother decided that she
wanted to have a little
daughter instead of a little son and so
she dressed him up like
a little daughter and now and now she
has him
trotted out protesting a law that would
prevent him from being mutilated and
castrated
that woman should be in prison she
should not be permitted around children
ever a just society
would would acknowledge that and codify
that into law
but we no longer have the ability to do
that
because on the left you've got them
actively pushing for this stuff
to trans the kids and castrate little
boys
and on the right the the best that we
can muster
is well you know not until he's 18.
well you know look i might not agree
with it but you know look it's freedom
you know well you know that's the that's
basically the best
that i'm not talking about you people
who listen to this show
i'm not talking about our friends here
who obviously have a more sophisticated
view of this
but i'm talking about the republican
leadership broadly speaking
they don't want to get into it they just
want to let the left run roughshod over
the culture even if it means mutilating
little boys freedom
we would have a freer country if that
kid's mother were in prison
and people like her we would have a
freer country if we recognized
limits to vice and licentiousness
and evil evil acts like castrating
little kids if we
if we took for the freedom if we took
the
the ability of these people to do these
sorts of things away from them
we would have a freer country because
liberty of course requires limitations
and licentiousness and liberty are not
synonyms but we're not not allowed to
acknowledge limits anymore
wait wait wait don't nope nope do not
not yet
you can't go until you smash
that subscribe button you hit that like
button you got to do it okay
or for other channels it's totally cool
youtube they love those channels they
promote them all the time
for us maybe they don't like exactly
what we're saying so head on over make
sure you subscribe
and never miss a video